kouda doit remplacer la batterie de son
auto chez le détaillant elle voit qu'un
montant supplémentaire de 20 $ plus
taxes est ajouté au prix de sa nouvelle
batterie c'est le dépôt de reprise ciel
rapporte sa vieille batterie pour
qu'elle soit le cycle et le dépôt lui
sera remboursé mais le lendemain on lui
rembourse 20 dollars sans les taxes ou
da est elle en train de se faire avoir
légalement non moralement un peu quand
même parce que les batteries ne sont pas
consigner les contenants consignés eux
ne sont pas taxés parce que la loi l'a
spécifié mais les batteries personne n'y
a pensé alors le gouvernement en case
ces taxes le genre d'absurdité que ruda
même pas trop mais il ya un truc si vous
rapportez votre vieille batterie lors de
l'achat de la nouvelle une seule
transaction sera faite et le dépôt ne
sera pas réclamé le fin mot de
l'histoire
une taxe pour rapporter sa batterie pour
les gens avertis c'est non merci